this mosque in kabul was packed with
people when a bomb exploded a prominent
cleric amir mohammed kabuli was killed
in the attack so were many of his
students
it was evening prayer time and i was
attending the prayers with others when
the explosion happened it was a very
powerful blast inside the mosque many
people were martyred and wounded
some of the victims were brought to this
hospital which is run by an italian
humanitarian organization
from the blast we received in total 35
patients
two were dead on arrival one died in our
emergency room eight received the
treatment and were later on discharged
while 24 are admitted in our hospital
mainly the injures are due to the shell
and burner
outside the hospital relatives waited
for news some of them were in the mosque
when the bomb exploded they said people
were hurled through the windows by the
force of the blast
it was a huge explosion
so many people were killed and injured i
brought two injured relatives to this
hospital
the taliban says security has improved
since it took power a year ago but
several attacks have taken place at
mosques in recent months
why does it happen i think uh
with the fall of kabul into the
ends of taliban somehow
this religious conflicts have been
considered
the biggest threat to the security of
afghanistan isis
has been
proactive in
its reaction to the taliban's gains
the taliban has been cracking down on
armed groups but this latest attack is a
reminder that security remains one of
its big challenges
victoria gatenbee al jazeera